weird guy can I ask you though quite I
know I'm not interrupting yeah but did
you grow up it just anything that you
saw you just named it and it was a pet
yeah there's a cockroach let's call it
Davy or whatever I might be you know can
I tell you a story about my dad and
cockroaches here we go I swear to you
yeah so my dad was a really strange
animal guy like he was one of those old
men that would probably have like a
[ __ ] falcon on his shoulder just
because he befriended it you know ages
ago but my dad had and I'm not joking
you a pet cockroach and it was a just a
random scariest-looking Filipino aerial
cockroach and that would have tea with
him and his eat the little bread crumbs
with him every morning and probably all
right that's not a copy babe hang on
can we call my mom and tell you this
story about a cockroach in the room your
uncle I'm gonna call my mom right now
[Laughter]
just don't tell her that we're on the
showcase the cockroach is like jean-luc
Picard he has Earl Grey tea and [ __ ]
scones with the data what the [ __ ] does
that mean we'll see okay
it's a rat than a cockroach or his
friends with just saying I'm having a
conversation with Bobby oh my gosh I'm
sure dad just didn't think it was a
different cockroach it was a different
cockroach every time you just assumed it
was the same one yes I think he's
mentally ill well no I think you don't
think so no because you know my dad was
a little hey MA hi MA I'm having an
argument with Bobby can you help me out
with something go to a place where I can
hear you better cuz you're cutting out
boom will my bunghole
go to a place cuz I can't hear you that
well you're cutting out but go to a
place with better waters
okay I can hear you much better okay mom
ma can you please explain to me that
story with Papa's pet and have tea with
him every morning okay tell me
so Bobby can hear you okay then what
happened to the mouse mom why did Papa
get upset about the mouse what's the
real story so my dad was you know he
[Music]
yeah so I just wanted to
it'd be my grandfather's father killed
my dad's mad when my dad came back from
the voyage cuz where's my mouse and my
mom didn't have the heart
a tragedy it's a tragic story of epic
divorces mom because Bobby thought that
I was lying about the pet cockroach and
the mouse and I just wanted to confirm
that he wasn't but I wasn't lying we
have the evidence now what what
sometimes I like to be bitten by a
cockroach because it gets really red and
itchy and it feels good to scratch it's
not true retract your statements it's
true okay my love you look I'm gonna
call you back it's crazy too much too
much you see when my mom doesn't know
she's on the podcast yeah she can talk
oh yeah Wow so I gathered so much
information from that number one number
I didn't realize there's things I
learned and what I didn't know is that
cockroaches and mice if you look at
their little arms
they have little watches cuz they they
show up on time time yeah there yeah
yeah I didn't realize that it's your fun
time for coffee and tea
to me or whatever I might be you know
number two I just
poor poor mouse poor mouse because
imagine like what if there were
creatures I just imagined this what if
they were creatures bigger than us right
and I saw that one of these creatures
you know at noon because I have a watch
new and I have a watch I go oh [ __ ] it's
a giant creature right mmm
has [ __ ] tea with me so I climb up
whatever it's table yeah and I you know
I mean and I'm we're talking about
philosophical things like Sartre Wow oh
yeah or whatever it might be or you know
mean Descartes or whatever it might be
and you talk about Rachmaninoff I mean
his composition so whatever you know you
were a smoking jacket yeah have a little
pipe you know and then one day he goes
hey hey little man I'm gonna go on a
voyage you're like oh good luck Magellan
I didn't know right he takes off and a
couple of days later that creatures
father throws a [ __ ] piano on me
that's basically what it is that's
exactly what that story is
mmm what a sad story my dad was real
sensitive about that stuff you know I
love your dad even you know I always
wish that I met Kyla's dad was so weird
he was such a scary scary dude to be
around even for me I'm a I was his
daughter and I would have